the bells is another guy I've lost touch
with for a lot of years and uh he was on
our show probably 50 [__] times at
least we did a lot of appearances yes
yeah he was great he'd come on he was a
very well-read guy and he was a comedian
so he would just rip on the news and
offer conspiracy theories I was most
proud of the fact the bells would come
on and riff and by riff I mean we talk
about different subjects or Robin would
read the news and the bells would
comment yeah I loved when he sat in on
the news because he was so well read he
was so well read and he had definite
opinions and that's good radio but one
time he was on the show and the famous
uh TV movie guy Barry Levinson was
listening to our show he heard the bells
he says that's the guy who should play
Detective Munch on TV here you go the
bells was best known for playing
detective John Munch for 22 consecutive
Seasons oh my God that job just kept on
going it was a record at the time the
character started on homicide life on
the street in 1993 then moved over to
Law and Order SVU in 1999. my favorite
memory of the Bells and it's such a
stupid memory and I don't know why I
love this so much but it happened off
the air Gilbert was Ill I've told that
story a million times I had to go see
Gilbert in the hospital so on the same
one of the days I'm there at Gilbert's
Hospital bedside Bells comes walking in
and you know Bells was kind of like this
um yeah man I was like yeah right yeah
right right yeah right like that was his
personality you know it's the best way
to put it Bells walks in looks at
Gilbert and I'm thinking oh my God this
is weird Bells is about to be emotional
nobody goes how you feeling
it was like oh you know and he goes okay
okay Belle sits down in a chair next to
Gilbert like one of those plastic
Hospital chairs right and opens up the
newspaper I think it was the Washington
Post
and he buries himself in the paper and
he starts reading the paper I was like
what the [__] is going on
no no no he just read the paper he was
just he was just sitting there with
Gilbert to just be there with him but he
didn't bother talking to him and I was
sitting there and I went you know what
I'm not gonna bother talking either so
we all just sat there maybe I had some
conversation would go over but it was
the funniest thing and then when the
bells was done reading the paper he got
up and laughed he basically you know
wished Gilbert well and said he'd be
back yeah it was the greatest thing I
ever saw in my life and the other big
story I remember with the Bells Bells
had a TV show on cable where he uh
interviewed people he had on Mr T and
Hulk Hogan
and the bells goes to those guys he goes
to Hulk Hogan now Mr T says hey can you
show me a wrestling move
but but Hulk Hogan for some reason put
him in a sleeper hold which actually
kind of knocks you out and then dropped
him on his head
and the bells was in bad [__] shape
and uh he actually ended up suing Hulk
Hogan and got about I think he sued him
for five million ended up getting
something like four hundred thousand
dollars he took the Belzer took the four
hundred thousand dollars bought himself
a place in France I said let's do a
demonstration and he put me in a what
they call a joke yeah
sleeper hold which if you look up in the
dictionary it says kill the Jew hole
specifically designed for Jews yeah and
so what it does is they cut off your
carotid artery and your brain you become
unconscious and then he let me fall to
the ground
nine stitches split my head open blood
gushing out oh he was unconscious on TV
and he managed to get up and say
which my doctor said you were in shock I
don't know how you did that yeah 2016
the bells retired from acting and lived
with his uh gorgeous wife Harley in
France yeah beautiful wife who and
here's a crazy thing Bell's friend Bill
Chef to former Late Show with David
Letterman writer told The Hollywood
Reporter that before his death Bells had
lots of health issues I didn't know that
yeah and his last words were [__] you
[__] and then he died to who I
did I was like is he saying that to Bill
who's he saying that but Bill then I
mean I don't know that's that's fine I
think you know I think he was trying to
be funny right up until the end
oh